guys you know no cat distribution system
The cat distribution system is the universe.
it sends cats to you guys
You're not the one asking.
or not you guys voted
I see
if you still remember or have followed the story
my cat new castle or apple
He suddenly appeared in front of the house.
I keep feeding you
even had time to
taken away by security
had been discarded by security
but a few hours later
made it back to my house again
he really is
I opened the door and went straight into the house.
as if you really want to
stay at my house or want to ask to be saved
with me
I also have a cat named Marakes.
This is the funny story of Marakes.
It was around 1.00 or 2.00 in the morning.
I'm having trouble sleeping
just start going to bed
then suddenly just heard the sound of a cat
ngeong ngeong The sound of a kitten
when I look out
Apparently there's this marakes midnight
I don't know where it came from.
Suddenly there was him in front of the house.
and he's still so little
even though it was yes a few days before
In my complex there is a stray cat control.
with the courage thrown away the wild cat
so the area of the house was sterile at that time
really in
There are no cats around the house at all.
Not there either
mother cat who has just given birth or a kitten
just calm down the atmosphere yes because
It was in the complex.
so strange suddenly there he was in the middle of the night appeared
out of nowhere and he was a little
If anyone follows the story of Paris.
He also had time to experience it.
a victim of stray cat control in my complex
It's because we love him.
He often eats on our porch.
we search for days
I never met
until about three months later
he went home alone to our house
Suddenly he came back and showed up alone to our house
shocked
sad emotion
I didn't think
how
You don't believe in the cat distribution system.
you guys have experienced